[موسيقى]
الفوائد من العمله الصعبه في كل الدول ما
هياش
بالسيوله الكافيه اللي تخلي في عمليات
استيراد لخامات او لخامات غبضه الذهب هو
من الخامات الغير ضروريه فاحنا شبه من اول
الثلاث سنين اللي فيهم الازمات ما ابتدات
وقفه عمليه الاستيراد لعدم وجود عمله صعبه
ادام الذهب كاسلعه لتوفير الدولار
للمستوردين فبالتالي بدا كلهم يكتبوا ان
هم يشتروا ذهب خام او او نصاب ذهب مثلا من
السوق ويبداوا يصدروها بغض النظر هي سعر
الدولار هيوقف عليهم بكام فبدات العمليه
بان لما كنا ب 24 و23 بدانا ب 27 29 30
وبدا الموضوع كل ما نضب عندك لان انت عندك
المخزون برده في الذهب بيقل فكل ما بيقل
كل من الاسعار بترتفع وهو ما عندهوش مشكله
طالما ان هو بيقدر
يصدر ويجيب الحصيله ويستخدم بها ويستخدمها
في الاستيراد هذه السلاح
[موسيقى]